and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review the expendables
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
yes boys
Silvio this movie called The Expendables
and it stars Oh everybody in the friggin
universe you hear Sylvester Stallone
Jason Statham is loyal
Jiraiya is an acre
you know I don't know his accent in Iran
to stop the evil Eric Roberts I always
know that Eric Roberts with evil he only
played the villain in every single movie
I was in
that's a dead giveaway so turns out the
CIA is the name this group of
Expendables into the island of Velveeta
to stop a bunch of bad guys but you see
Eric Roberts used to be a member of the
CIA
so rather than the CIA take him out
risking been pressing in the Expendables
in an EVO double-cross shots are thrown
women scream and our actors say things
that you can't possibly comprehend yeah
I
I don't look great
well it's kinda true see Schwarzenegger
and whether it's only make a brief cameo
you see Willis is like to stuff okay and
Swardson a you're Zack I am honest well
to make a buying but here's a friggin
awesome
just seen them in the same room is so
cool playing horseshoes together in the
world could still explode actually
happens hated yes my balls in a wild
boar I hate a wild boar once it was kind
of like that except there was my balls
seriously it's the only thing missing
from this movie was Van Damme Seagal and
Snipes
but I heard being damned into it because
he's an idiot tonight's dinner cause he
cheated us Texas has a golden time
because I refer you to the fend in steam
but it was awesome but it was so awesome
it was just like commando and all those
other cheesy action films like those
high school kids were like hey we have
no identity let's rip off the 80s I mean
like the real legit shit so if you want
to see shit blow up shit blow up or ship
blew up I highly recommend fireworks but
after that that's mommy my testicles
kill the wild poor this is Jerry Busey